السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد
ان
اله
الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان محمدا
رسول
الله حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على الصلاه
حي على
[Silence]
الفلا حي على الفلا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا اله
الا
[Silence]
الله الحمد لله الحمد لله الخالق بجود من
العدم وجاعل نور من الظلم ومخرج سبل من
الالم ف مليقي توبتي على ال ندم فنشكر على
المصائب كما نشكر على النعم نصلي على رسول
الاكرم ذي شرف الاشم ونول الاتم وكتاب
المحكم وكمال النبيين وخاتم سيد والدي ادم
الذي بشر به عيسى بن مريم وداع بحته
ابراهيم عليه الصلاه والسلام حين كان يرفع
بيت الله المحرم فصلى الله عليه وسلم
وعلى اتباه خير الامم الذي بارك الله به
كافه الناس العرب من العجم والحمد لله
الذي لم يتخذ ولدا ولم يكن له شريك في
الملك ولم يكن له ولي من الذ وكبره تكبيرا
والحمد لله الذي انزل على عبده كتابا ولم
يجعل له عوجا والحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهدي الله فلا مضل له
ومن يدلله فلا هادي له واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا
عبده
ورسوله صفي بخلق وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وعد
الامانه ونصح الامه وكشف الله تعالى به
غمه وجاهد في الله حق جهاد حتى اتاه
اليقين اما بعد قال الله سبحانه وتعالى في
القران المجيد والفرقان الحميد ماذا اعوذ
بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تمتن الا وانم مسلمون وقال الله
سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم
من ذكر وانثى وجعلناكم عوبا وقبائله
لتعارفوا ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم ان
الله عليم خبير ثم اما بعد ان اصدق الكتاب
كتاب الله تعالى وخير هدي هدي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم وشر امور محدثها وكل محدثه
بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله في النار
ربي اشرح لي صدري ويسر لي امري واحلل عقده
من لساني يفقه قولي اللهم لا سحل الا ما
جعلته سحلا وانت تجعل الحزن اذا شئت سحلا
ولا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
الله ربنا وقتنا ورنا ومولانا فنعم
المنهالى
[Silence]
مح صلى الله عليه وسلمان
الله سبحانه
وتالى حث
[Silence]
حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
صهص الرسي
[Silence]
حث عليه اله
والسلام الدعاء مخ
العبا
دعا worship الله
سهال a
formation حث عليهه
واللام
فحب فح الكتاب الفاتح الكب الحمد رب
العالمين
الفحه الله سبحان
وتالم رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ليس
شيء اكرم على الله من الدعاء
‏h
it are
ask الله
سبحانى ومن اضل ومن اضل ممن يدعوا من دون
الله من لا ي يستجيب له الى اليوم القيامه
وهم عن دعائهم
دون
الله my and needs
might in ence to
something
سال
as increasing decreasing
[Silence]
يدعوا من دون الله من لا يستجيب
له
الله الى اليوم القيامه
وهم عن دعائ
غون الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
اللهانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى
الله
سانال الله سبحانه
وتالى الله
سبهالى you know there there is
نصد
[Silence]
وذ عليه
ياس
افري ‏take care of me take care of my
ises and one ss up and
say الله سبحان وتال
resp ليك
يا م
عليهه
الله
الله ask he
was up wasing id
الله سبحان وتالى م علسلام musa
is some who has the et eternal
being who is some besides me even he s
up i'm here i answer his
pray gives a glimp الله سبحانه
وتالى as
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم اذنب عبد
ذنبا فقال اللهم اغفرلي ذنبي فقال تبارك
الله تعالى اذنب عبدي ذنبا فعلم ان له ربا
يغفر
الذنب الله سهال
الله سبحانه
وتالى اللفر
الله
اللفر
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى ع عبدي ذبا فعلم ان له رب
ثمد
فن
فقال
فري فقال تبارك الله تعالى
عبدي
اذنب ذنبا فعلم ان له ربا يغفر
الذنب ثم
عاد فاذن
رب الله
سبحانه الله سبحانه
و الله سبحانه وى فقد غفرت لك فليفعل ما
‏as الله
سبحانى have
anding iner
form is lord and master
have we can come back over and over over
over
again الله سانال
بخاري
مسلمش الله سبحان وتالى من يدعوني يدعوني
فاستجب
له من يسالني
فاعت ومن يستغفرني
فاغفر there
الله
سانال اذا سالك عبادي عني فاني قريب اجيب
دعوه الداعي اذا
دعا او محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم ‏where
i tell i
close اجيبوه داي اذا and
i
ask ask there
to الله سبحانه
وتالى as
[Silence]
وتالى
‏my goodness my
think before youer
‏time اللهانه
وتالى
الله اللهانه
الله
سبحتى الله
سبحانى that
be we
need سانتال
قولوا ما تسمعون استغفر الله لي ولكم
وسائل المسلمين كل ذنب فاستغفر له ان
الغفور
الرحيم بسم الله الحمد لله الواحد الاحد
الفضل الصمد الذي لم يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن
له كفوا
احد رواء مسلم عن ابي ذر رضي الله عنه عن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فيما روى عن عن
الله تبارك وتعالى انه قال يا عبدي لو ان
اولكم واخركم وانسكم وجنكم قاموا في سعيد
واحد فسالوني فاعطيت كل انسان مسالته ما
نقص ذلك مما عندي الا كما ينقص المخ
المخيت اذا ادخل البحر
اوق ما قال عليه الصلاه
والسلام
ممي رضي الله عن رسول الله صلس الله
سبحانه
وتالى ل ان اولكم واخركم
‏all
all
one
own
one will give each one of you their need
it does not decrease in my aven my
reven
a into
[Silence]
‏how
‏every soul there all asked and one of
notes
andes why
are why are
afn and are af to ra our
hands we are always so open with our
friends and our
famili discussing our ises our stres we
[Silence]
الله
‏around you how they remind you over and
over again for the simp
things repe every seconds minut the
same until you give in and say you know
what yes you can have that's the way
الله
سال
from
from need relation
سهال
[Silence]
اهه عن رحمه الله
عليهن تم
[Silence]
الفاتحه اياك نعبد وايا
نعين
الله لا اله الا انت سبحانك اني كنت من
الظالمين الله
[Silence]
‏can are all
‏ins mann
ask things that
ines
give
how
ask
in
mayans
andil to be a person who isca to him at
all times
اللهانه وتالى الله سبحانه وتاله
[Silence]
اللهم دائ فمنهم اللهم لا تدع لنا ذبا الا
غفرته ولا هما الا فرجته ولا كربا الا
نفسته ولا ميتا الا رحمته ولا مريض الا
شافيته ولا دنا الا
قضيته ولا دنا الا قض ولا مي الا رحمت
ولا اولادا الا اصلحت ولا عيبا الا سطرت
ولا حاجه من حوا رضنا قضيتها ويسرتها لنا
اللهم ان كان رزقنا في السماء فانزله و
كان رزق في الارض فاخرجه و كان بعيدا
فقربه كان قريبا فيسره كان قليلا فكثره من
كان كثيرا فبارك لنا فيه اللهم انسر اسلام
المسلمين اللهم انسر اسلام المسلمين اللهم
انصر دينك وكتابك اللهم انصر نبيك محمد
وعبادك الصالحين اللهم اذ ل شرك المشرك
ودمر اعداء الدين اللهم انسر اخوان
المستضعفين في فلسطين اللهم انسر اخوان
المعفي فلسطين وفي السودان وفي كل مكان
ربنا تقبل منا انك السميع العليم وتوب
علينا يا مك التواب الرحيم عباد الله ان
الله وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا ايها
الذين امنوا صلوا عليه وسلم تسليما اللهم
سلم وبارك و عبدك محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين عباد الله ان الله يامركم العدل
والاحسان وتا القرب وانح فشاء منكر بغي
يعزكم لعلكم تذكرون اذكر الله العظيم
اذكركم واشكر زكم وذكر الله اكبر وقوموا
الى ص يرحمكم
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد ان لا
اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه حي على الصلاه حي على
الفلاح حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
استص الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الض
ين
امينم ويل لكل همزه
لمزه الذي جمع مالا
وعدده يحسب ان ماله
اخلده كلا لي
بذن في
الحطمه
وما ادراك ما
الحطمه نار الله
الموقده التي تطلع على
الافئده انها عليهم
مؤصده في
عمد
ممدده الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين ام
امين قل هو الله احد الله
الصمد لم يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
لام
‏now year
‏gr to some upside in the com so i just
to make we do not forg for this year and
working next after that
second now we have the chance to make we
need some teachers for academy and any
interest
‏and last but not least we are going be
the exp of the class room class being we
talking some fund and have per
now you be lev acity outside and that's
right outside m hallway on the other
side the building so other side of the
gym so when you see being moved landc
being ched don't pic
[Silence]
‏pleas
الله
‏b
[Silence]
الله اكب
بس
[Silence]
س ان